Speaker 1: One of the things that kind of pervades
much right wing ideology, at least in the United
States, is seemingly simple, obvious ideas
that everybody should clearly hear and
immediately say that makes sense and adopt,
which require no real deep thought of
any kind. And these include things like,
Hey, it's your money. After all, why should you be
taxed? It's your money, and you should get to keep
it pretty simple. I don't know. It makes sense.
Of course, the real world is far more complicated.
Hey, listen. I mean, we've got a Second Amendment,
and so that's it. Just people can have whatever
guns and but. Well, we'll hold on a second. Let
let's let's actually think more deeply about some
of these issues. And when it comes to things like
unemployment. Welfare benefits, social insurance,
there's this attitude from the right that's often
based on the concept of people just got to stop
being lazy and just like going do stuff, go and
do stuff. You need more money, get a better job.
Just just just go, go, go, do stuff. Don't, don't
rely on other people, don't be lazy. All of these
different things. And along these lines, a
very popular meme that now is being repeated
very uncritically on Fox News. And another right
wing media is as Omicron spreads wildly and some
health agencies in different states, countries,
et cetera, are saying employers should be prepared
for up to 25 percent of their workforce at any
given time to be out because of either a COVID
diagnosis or a COVID exposure that requires some
degree of isolation. They are saying just just go
to work, go to work, and we have the epitome of
hypocrisy here. From Fox News's Brian Kilmeade.
The Fox and Friends crew appears to be hosting
Fox and Friends each alone in studios. Now,
we can't tell whether these are all even Fox
Studios or Summer Home studios. There are
people on other networks who have set up a room
in their home with a big TV screen behind them,
and it looks like they're in the studio.
But they're really at home, we don't know.
But Brian Kilmeade, while he is co-hosting Fox
and Friends alone in a studio rather than on the
couch with his co-hosts for any of a variety
of different reasons, is telling other people
Just go to work and live with COVID, just just
get out there. What are you doing trying to
be at home, trying to be out for work? Pretty
convenient when you can just get it, get your
own studio or whatever it is that he's doing all
right. Let's take a look at the video here, and
Speaker 7: I want to make it clear to
that. I met so many teachers and angel,
your sister's teacher and your mom was teacher and
I met so many teachers. I went over 18 cities over
the last two months. And why people say, I know
Fox as my teachers, I know you got it all wrong.
The fact is, in all teachers, the unions that are
controlled, that they're forced to join in order
to get a job. That's the issue. But guess what?
It's changed. You know what used to be used to be
us on the couch. They used to be almost every
Republican political leader. Almost everyone
saying, Go get the kids back in school. And
the Democrats get in charge. And it's like,
No, no, we're going to. We need money to get
schools ready. And six feet apart. And then we
have plexiglass in order to get. And then all of
a sudden things have changed. If you see the new
mayor of New York City, if you see Lori Lightfoot
of Chicago, if you see what is happening in Los
Angeles, everywhere you go in Massachusetts,
the moderate governor, a Republican governor
who has really gone liberal on so many different
causes, is now pushing back, all on the same page,
saying kids need to be in school. And guess the
only people standing in the way are teachers
unions. The kids need to be in school. The parents
need to be teaching in school. The mayor saying,
get into school. The governors are saying, get
him school. The president saying in the school,
Dr. Fauci said, get to school. They're the
only thing stopping these kids are going to.
Speaker 1: Now, remember, all along, everybody
said it would be better for kids to be in school.
There was a point at which it would have
been outrageous to do it and schools this.
I mean, we're we're getting to the main thing.
Even this week, some schools are saying we're
going to we're going to go remote for a
week or two weeks and try to get past this,
this immigrant surge. But let's continue
Speaker 7: their learning curve forever curtailed
unless something happens quickly, and this should
be a march from here on in. Let's not get caught
up in the daily nuances of what doctors in and
what's out. It's called live with it. Go to work
live with it. Go to try to get on a train. Get
on a bus. Get on a plane. How do we live with
it? We can no longer hide from it. That's
the ten day to five day rule. Now, listen,
in the real world, there's parents that
have to deal with remote learning until
they can get control of their kid's education.
Speaker 1: Now there's some degree to which
kill is not wrong in that we are literally going
to have to learn to live with it one way or the
other. How some people live with it is going to
be different than how other people live with it.
The most optimistic scenario is we've got another
seven to 10 days, maybe of this omicron surge and
then a decline meaning in seven to 10 days, we'll
be back where we are now. And in another seven
to 10 days will be to where we were seven to 10
days ago and hopefully six weeks from now or so.
Things are looking here the way they were.
They are looking in South Africa now.
That would be the ideal trajectory. But then the
best case scenario is this thing becomes endemic
and it will be roughly this severe for a
period of time. And hopefully over time,
the number of cases gets down to, you know, what
would be sort of a steady, predictable level the
way flu sort of is. Although there's better flu
seasons and worst flu seasons, we know that.
And it continues to mutate because. Of
evolutionary pressure that generally makes
these things less severe over time rather
than more in the less severe direction,
so there is a degree to which we have to live with
it. We are in the middle of the biggest spike.
Fox and Friends are each sitting by themselves
in a studio, as he is saying, Get on a bus,
go to school, go hear teachers, go and go.
Even when when you have a lot of kids still
unvaccinated. Very easy and hypocritical for
him to say that. And you know, it was the AOC.
The thing they were saying about AOC going to
Miami, which we talked about rules for the and
not for me. He's telling everybody else, get on
public transit and just go to your job where he
is. You know, we can't tell he may be working
from home or isolated in a studio, probably gets
a chauffeured ride into the studio. Or at least
it's available. I don't know if he's taking it,
you know, we're sort of guessing here. This is
sort of a rules for the not for me sort of thing
and just a complete disconnect from the reality
of what's actually going on in the world. And if
businesses have 25 percent, 25 percent of workers
out, you don't think that cripples businesses in
a serious and significant long term way. So it's
not just hypocrisy, it's virtue signaling as well.
And we should all be really skeptical about
accepting the stuff that these people tell us.